Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In the last few years, the pace of progress
in machine learning research has been staggering.
Neural network-based learning algorithms are
now able to look at an image and describe
what’s seen in this image, or even better,
the other way around, generating images from
a written description.
You see here a set of results from BigGAN,
a state of the art image generation technique
and marvel at the fact that all of these images
are indeed synthetic.
The GAN part of this technique abbreviates
the term Generative Adversarial Network - this
means a pair of neural networks that battle
each over time to master a task, for instance,
to generate realistic looking images when
given a theme.
These detailed images are great, but, what
about generating video?
With the Dual Video Discriminator GAN, DVD-GAN
in short, DeepMind’s naming game is still
as strong as ever, it is now possible to create
longer and higher-resolution videos than was
previously possible, the exact numbers are
256x256 in terms of resolution and 48 frames,
which is about 2 seconds.
It also learned the concept of changes in
the camera view, zooming in on an object,
and understands that if someone draws something
with a pen, the ink has to remain on the paper
unchanged.
The Dual Discriminator part of the name reveals
one of the key ideas of the paper.
In a classical GAN, we have a discriminator
network that looks at the images of the generator
network and critiques them.
As a result, this discriminator learns to
tell fake and real images apart better, but
at the same time, provides ample feedback
for the generator neural network so it can
come up with better images.
In this work, we have not one, but two discriminators,
one is called the spatial discriminator that
looks at just one image and assesses how good
it is structurally, while the second, temporal
discriminator critiques the quality of the
movement in these videos.
This additional information provides better
teaching for the generator, which will in
return, be able to generate better videos
for us.
The paper contains all the details that you
could possibly want to learn about this algorithm,
in fact, let me give you two that I found
to be particularly interesting: one, it does
not get any additional information about where
the foreground and the background is, and
is able to leverage the learning capacity
of these neural networks to learn these concepts
by itself.
And two, it does not generate the video frame
by frame sequentially, but it creates the
entire video in one go.
That’s wild.
Now, 256x256 is not a particularly high video
resolution, but if you have been watching
this series for a while, you are probably
already saying that two more papers down the
line, and we may be watching HD videos that
are also longer than we have the patience
to watch.
And all this through the power of machine
learning research.
For now, let’s applaud DeepMind for this
amazing paper, and I can’t wait to have
a look at more results and see some followup
works on it.
What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!